hoffnung auf massentest millionen
deutsche könnten in den nächsten wochen
auf corona antikörper untersucht werden
immer mehr unterschiedliche pläne und
regeln nach sachsen-anhalt prescht jetzt
auch wieder sachsen mit weiteren
lockerungen vor und schlag für die
angehörigen nach 184 verhandlungstagen
wird der loveparade prozess ohne urteil
eingestellt
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen schön dass sie dabei sind
der gesundheitsminister nennt es eine
wichtige wegmarke im kampf gegen korona
ein schweizer pharmakonzern hat einen
antikörper test entwickelt der noch in
diesem monat millionenfach in
deutschland ausgeliefert werden kann
der test zeigt ob jemand das virus schon
überstanden hat denn dann hat der
antikörper entwickelt ob die wirklich
immun machen gegen das virus ist
allerdings noch nicht endgültig bewiesen
und offen ist auch ob dieser test
tatsächlich genauer ist als andere
patricia schäfer berichtet bayerns
ministerpräsident sünder ist stolz ein
neuer corona antikörper test entwickelt
im bayerischen penzberg millionenfach
soll er bereits ab diesem monat zur
verfügung stehen und die tests
kapazitäten in deutschland deutlich
erhöhen
auch der bundesgesundheitsminister war
heute bei der vorstellung des neuen
labortest dabei es ist ein tester in
deutschland entwickelt wurde die
forschung hat ja stattgefunden er wird
hier produziert beides ist sehr sehr
wichtig für deutschland als standort
aber eben auch in dieser krone epidemie
dass wir zügig zu neuen erkenntnissen
kommen das ist ihr mit großem einsatz
geschehen und das wir vor andern diesen
test auch verfügbar haben für
deutschland und für europa 3 millionen
der antikörper test kits soll noch im
mai an gesundheitseinrichtungen in
deutschland ausgeliefert werden
50.000 allein an eine münchner
universität ein wichtiger schritt um die
dunkelziffer der korona infizierten zu
erkennen bayern will darüber hinaus dazu
beitragen ein bio technisches
forschungszentrum am standort des
pharmariesen aufzubauen
ich glaube gerade den bereichen medizin
im bereich pharmazie brauchen wir
dringend wieder mehr eigenkapital in
deutschland was wir doch gemerkt haben
ist das ist ein fehler war dass allen
anderen landen teilen der welt zu
überlassen wir müssen hier produzieren
wir müssen hier noch mehr mehr forschen
ab jetzt muss sich der test in der
praxis beweisen wenn diverse labore die
materialien geliefert bekommen deshalb
sind wir logan noch vorsichtig in der
bewertung die frage bei solchen testen
ist immer wie spezifisch sind die das
heißt wie genau sind die und da sagt die
firma roche sei ihr test sehr gut
das muss man jetzt sicherlich im
vergleich der anderen teste die es gibt
einfach noch mal überprüfen
in den nächsten wochen wird man sehen
wie genau antikörper gegen das neuartige
corona virus angezeigt werden
im einsatz ist der test ab sofort in den
usa und auch in den eu-staaten wie viele
menschen sich tatsächlich schon mit dem
virus infiziert haben
dazu gibt es jetzt auch interessante
ergebnisse aus der heinsberg studie
rheinsberg das ist der kreis in
nordrhein westfalen wo sich der erreger
nach einer karnevalssitzung massiv
ausbreitete
die zahlen aus der gemeinde gangelt
haben die forscher um den bonner
virologen streik auf deutschland
hochgerechnet demnach könnten sich
bereits 1,8 millionen menschen infiziert
haben gut zehnmal mehr als bisher
registriert die ganze welt sucht im
moment mittel gegen korona vor allem
einen impfstoff nach dem motto gemeinsam
sind wir schneller und stärker hat die
eu-kommission zu einer internationalen
geberkonferenz geladen
auch mit dem ziel dass ein künftiger
impfstoff für alle verfügbar ist
allerdings machen große staaten wie usa
oder russland nicht mit aus brüsseler
klinik ein hauch von eurovision liegt
über der internationalen geberkonferenz
eu-kommissionspräsident in ursula von
der leyen ruft aus brüssel
die teilnehmer einzeln auf staats und
regierungschefs den direktor der
weltgesundheitsorganisation
internationale stiftungen alle sagen
brav geld zu das helfen soll einen
impfstoff zu entwickeln
zudem alle menschen zugang haben sollen
die bundesregierung verspricht 525
millionen euro soforthilfe ich finde
dies in einer zeit in der wir nicht
immer multilateral so zusammenarbeiten
wie ich mir das wünsche ein ganz
wichtiges signal heute es ist eine
stunde der hoffnung bis zum abend sind
so 7,4 milliarden euro
anschubfinanzierung zusammengekommen
davon sollen circa vier milliarden in
die entwicklung eines impfstoffs gehen
zwei milliarden in die herstellung von
anti corona medikamenten und 1,5
milliarden euro in die produktion von
tests verteilt werden die gelder über
eine forschungsplattform und die
internationale impfstoff allianz
doch es gibt noch viele fragen das ist
unklar wer konkret die forschung die
produktion und die verteilung sowohl von
impfstoffen diagnostika und medikamente
organisieren wird es ist bisher nicht
sichergestellt dass ausreichend
bedingungen an die vergabe der
öffentlichen gelder geknüpft sind das
tatsächlich ein bezahlbarer preis zum
schluss bei rauskommt fast noch
wichtiger als die bedeutende rednerliste
ist aber wer fehlt sowohl russland als
auch die finanzstarke us regierung
nehmen nicht teil
präsident trump hatte der
weltgesundheitsorganisation fehler
vorgeworfen und angekündigt die suche
nach einem impfstoff national
voranzutreiben
die eu kommission als co gastgeberin
versucht mit dieser konferenz
wettzumachen was sie zu beginn der
korona krise an koordination verpasst
hat die summe ist beeindruckend doch der
schwierige teil kommt jetzt dafür zu
sorgen dass ein impfstoff gefunden
produziert und gerecht verteilt wird
für den aktuellen zahlen in deutschland
da zeigt sich an den angaben der johns
hopkins universität ein trend nach unten
durchschnittlich haben sich in den
vergangenen sieben tagen jeweils 1000
130 menschen neu angesteckt insgesamt
sind stand vor einer halben stunde fast
166.000 infektionen durch tests
bestätigt davon gelten knapp 133.000
betroffene als genesen und 6866 menschen
starben in verbindung mit kubik 19
je mehr die infektionszahlen sinken
desto größer wird der druck auf bund und
länder weitere lockerungen zuzulassen
oder zumindest zeitpläne in aussicht zu
stellen
übermorgen beraten kanzlerin und
ministerpräsidenten doch längst preschen
einige wieder vor
nach sachsen-anhalt heute auch
niedersachsen dort sollen ab montag
gaststätten wieder öffnen dürfen ab ende
mai auch hotels christoph distel hat
details im leine gold in hannover zählen
sie die tage runter 7 noch dann dürfen
sie wieder ein echtes restaurant seien
echte gäste empfangen wird georg geplant
und übt schon mal corona ab
wir werden mit mundschutz und
schutzhandschuhen arbeiten und natürlich
regelmäßig wie es auch vor der
schließung schon war händewaschen selber
desinfizieren und dafür sorgen dass
unsere gäste so sicher wie möglich bei
uns aufgehoben sind vielleicht nur eine
prise normalität für die
niedersächsischen restaurants aber so
viel mehr als anderswo
ein corona gesamtkonzept macht's möglich
fünf stufen hat sich das land für das
ganze öffentliche leben vorgenommen nur
so macht sinn meint der
ministerpräsident wollen wir eigentlich
weiterhin immer von einzelfall zu
einzelfall springen oder müssen wir
jetzt nicht uns auch die zeit nehmen
über einen gesamtplan miteinander zu
reden und an dieser stelle sind wir
niedersachsen eben auch mit unserem
vorschlag jetzt vorangegangen auch
sachsen anhalt will sich mehr trauen
erlaubt seit heute bis zu fünf menschen
nah beieinander freunde
zufallsbekanntschaften egal bei relativ
wenig infizierten kann man das wagen
heißt es dass freud und macht sorge mal
zu zweit grillen war schon ein bisschen
eintönig aber jetzt zu fünf meter ein
bisschen mehr um ein solches schön
vorsichtig sein
noch nicht dass sie jetzt wieder in
rudeln auftreten und es könnten wir
zweite welle kommen die ketten auch für
schlimmer werden und da ist er nun der
korona regel flickenteppich in
deutschland im kampf gegen virus und
rezession zugleich müssen auch die
vorsichtigen akzeptieren aber wichtig
ist schon klar dass laut gesetzgebung
ist nur einfach mal so ist dass jedes
land seine entscheidung treffen muss es
hat sich übrigens auch insofern bewährt
ich rate uns weiter zu umsicht und
vorsicht jedes land nach seiner art
findet auch der regierungssprecher
ein system aber besonders wichtig es ist
immer so gewesen und auch allseits
anerkannt worden
das ist natürlich regionale lokale
chancen geben kann aber das wichtige ist
die gemeinsame strategie die möchten
bund und länder übermorgen nachjustieren
und es gibt zu justieren die bundesweite
öffnung von restaurants etwa steht noch
gar nicht auf der tagesordnung wenn sie
den überblick behalten wollen was in
welchem bundesland erlaubt ist und was
nicht in der zdf- heute haben wir alles
wichtige zusammengestellt die aktuellen
corona virus regeln auf 1
blick von vielen sehnsüchtig erwartet im
ganzen land haben seit heute friseure
wieder auf allerdings bis einiges anders
es gibt zum beispiel keinen kaffee und
auch keinen haarschnitt ohne wäsche
alles um infektionen zu vermeiden
steffen dax hat sich das in hamburg
angeschaut ungewohnt zu ihnen trocken
haarschnitt gibt's nicht mehr an die
wäsche vorab muss er sich gewöhnen als
klar war dass heute aufgemacht wird habe
ich sofort versucht mit den ersten
termin zu sichern weil wenn nicht
einzeln so dass lange habe das hier
jetzt einiges anders läuft damit haben
die meisten kein problem
nach der zwangspause brummt der laden
wieder aber darf wir müssen alle die
strengen hygiene auflagen einhalten
heike und bürger kenzler haben zuvor in
ihrem salon für die notwendigen schutz
gesorgt und wegen das erforderliche
mindestabstand arbeitsplätze abgebaut
das heißt sie haben keine chance den
umsatz aufzuholen weil sie gar nicht die
kunden in der frequenz bearbeiten dürfen
und können auch körperlich nicht können
wie sie müssten um diese sechs wochen
aufzuholen der schnitt wird teurer die
hygiene auflagen fordern mehr zeit pro
kunde desinfektionsmittel masken
handschuhe kosten geld verden mit maske
ist kompliziert der kunde ist im schnitt
doppelt so lange im salon
bislang gab es in hamburg weder
insolvenzen noch entlassungen dann
kurzarbeit und corona soforthilfen alle
werden es aber wohl nicht schaffen was
ich frühestens in einem vierteljahr
zeigen dann würde ich sagen
zehn prozent der betriebe wobei es da
betriebe wahrscheinlich treffen wird die
schon vor corona schwierigkeiten hatten
die kanzlers bezeichnen den chor
unerlaubter und scherzhaft als teuersten
urlaub ihres lebens sind aber
optimistisch dass kingston alle termine
ausgebucht
über die grenze rüber nach deutschland
um zu arbeiten vor krone einer
normalität in den letzten wochen aber
höchst problematisch beispiel polen
berufspendler aus dem grenzgebiet
durften zwar weiter nach deutschland
einreisen konnten aber quasi nicht mehr
zurück weil sie in ihrer heimat sofort
in quarantäne gekommen wären
es gab klagen und proteste jetzt hat
polen die regelung zurückgenommen
natalie steger
wochenlang vor den familien getrennt
jetzt können sie es nicht erwarten
punkt mitternacht in görlitz ist pablo
der erste polnische kehrer aus
deutschland ich habe lange auf diesen
moment gewartet seit die grenzen
geschlossen waren
entschuldigung ich habe es eilig ich
will zu meiner familie polnische
berufspendler an der grenze bei görlitz
auf dem weg zurück nach polen ohne
danach zwei wochen zu hause in
quarantäne zu müssen
medizinisches personal pflegekräfte aber
sind explizit von der lockerung
ausgenommen da bleibt die quarantäne
pflicht in polen für handwerker etwa und
servicekräfte nun nicht mehr drei wochen
haben wir auf diese rückkehr gewartet
wir arbeiten in einem sägewerk an der
grenze wir sortieren da holz polnische
pendler konnten die letzten wochen zwar
nach deutschland zur arbeit gehen ohne
dort in quarantäne zu müssen aber zurück
in polen hätten sie dann bis gestern in
quarantäne festgesessen
in bezug auf den arbeitsmarkt war die
schließung sicherlich ein fehler
der beweis ist jetzt die schnelle
beziehungsweise ziemlich schnelle
reaktion der regierung unter änderung
dieser unnötigen dummen entscheidung wer
ungehindert pendeln will muss seinen
arbeitsvertrag dabei haben denn die
polnischen grenzkontrollen dauern noch
bis mindestens 13 mal in kleinen
schritten zurück zur normalität danach
sehnen sich wohl alle besonders auch die
italiener
sie erlebten mit corona die katastrophe
völlig überforderte ärzte mehr als
29.000 tote seit fast zwei monaten gilt
eine radikale ausgangssperre
seit heute wagt das land wieder ein
bisschen mehr freiheit und hofft dass
diese nicht eine zweite ansteckungswelle
auslöst aus rom andreas postel
der erste kaffee auf dem weg zur arbeit
nach acht wochen strengem lockdown in
rom handwerker daniele spinelli freut
sich über dieses italienische
grundbedürfnis es ist ein schönes gefühl
lange her dass wir einen kaffee geholt
ab heute kann man endlich wieder
einnehmen
das aufatmen ist deutlich zu spüren
überall im land nach den
entbehrungsreichen wochen und der
strengen einschränkungen elementare
freiheitsrechte
besonders die wirtschaft macht druck
schrittweise dürfen nun wichtige
produktionszweige wieder anlaufen
auch parks und ab heute wieder geöffnet
sport im freien ist erlaubt und
verwandte dürfen besucht werden alles
unter weiterhin strengen auflagen joggen
maximal zu zweit ausflüge beschränkt auf
die eigene region
es ist ein brisanter moment denn wie
hier auf dem bahnhof in mailand strömen
die menschen zur arbeit es herrscht
masken pflicht in allen öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln und am eingang
temperatur scanner flächendeckend die
angst ist groß dass sich das corona
virus wieder stärker ausbreiten könnte
die italienische regierung selbst
rechnet in phase 2 mit einem anstieg der
neuinfektionen diese soll nun schnell
verfolgt werden um eine neue
infektionskette zu verhindern
italien tastet sich ganz vorsichtig
zurück mit umfangreichen antikörper test
soll nun festgestellt werden inwieweit
italiener bereits eine immunität
entwickelt haben und ab mitte mai will
auch italien eine corona app einführen
allerdings auf freiwilliger basis die
bewegungsfreiheit ist weiter
eingeschränkt und kinder müssen in
italien voraussichtlich noch bis
september auf die öffnung ihrer schulen
warten zurück nach deutschland und weg
von corona für die hinterbliebenen ist
es ein schlag der prozess zur loveparade
wird eingestellt vor fast zehn jahren
starben auf dem technofestival in
duisburg 21 junge leute bei einer
massenpanik mehr als 650 menschen wurden
verletzt
schnell war die rede von planungsfehlern
das sicherheitskonzept sei nicht
ausgereift gewesen
trotz weiterhin offener fragen endet das
mammut verfahren jetzt ohne urteil
dominik müller roussel berichtet
ende eines mammutprozesses und zugleich
ende aller hoffnungen darauf dass doch
noch ein urteil gesprochen wird und
schuldige benannt werden für die
massenpanik bei der loveparade vor nur
eineinhalb jahren gabi müller verlor
damals ihren sohn christian
das schlimmste war der tag hat hier
unsere kinder verloren haben
und dann dieser weg neuneinhalb jahre
hoffen glauben enttäuschung so wie soll
man damit umgeht
184 prozesstage lang hat das landgericht
duisburg versucht zu klären wie es zu
der katastrophe kam die erkenntnis ganz
viele verantwortliche haben fehler
gemacht bei den planungen im vorfeld und
bei entscheidungen am tag selbst der
vorsitzende richter hat ausgeführt dass
es in diesem verfahren nicht den einen
schwerwiegend böses tun denn bösewicht
gegeben hat aber eine ganze vielzahl von
leuten die fehler gemacht und insoweit
auch eine gewisse schuld auf sich
geladen haben da es sich aber um ein
weit verzweigtes multi causales
geschehen handelt ist die schuld der
einzelnen teilnehmer gering dieser
partie als aus spanien waren an allen
wichtigen prozesstagen dabei heute
konnten sie nicht kommen wegen corona
sie haben damals ihre tochter clara
verloren enttäuschung in der ferne
wir werden uns die entscheidung des
gerichts genau durchlesen sie mit
unseren anwälten besprechen und wir
werden uns weitere rechtliche schritte
offen halten viele fehler bei der
loveparade aber nun kein urteil keine
verantwortlichen keine strafen für die
angehörigen ein sehr frustrierendes
prozess ende
unsere rechts expertin sarah attacke ist
zugeschaltet sarah die fassungslosigkeit
der angehörigen kann jeder
nachvollziehen warum ist es juristisch
so schwer schuldige für eine solche
katastrophe zu finden je nach solchen
katastrophen fragen angehörige fragt
sich jeder der davon etwas erfährt der
herz und hirn hat wie konnte es dazu
kommen und wer ist dafür verantwortlich
dass wie es zu dieser katastrophe kommen
konnte hat dieses verfahren sehr
detailliert aufgearbeitet und es hat
auch verantwortliche benannte sind auch
verantwortliche angeklagt worden
denn es sind natürlich menschen
verantwortlich im moralischen sinne aber
auch im juristischen sinne aber und das
haben wir bei solchen katastrophen
juristisch immer wieder
sie sind im gerichtssaal nur schwer zu
fassen und führen selten zu verurteilung
und es liegt daran dass es am ende eine
vielzahl von verantwortlichen gibt eine
vielzahl von fehlern gemacht wurden bei
der planung bei der kontrolle im am tag
selber bei einzelnen entscheidungen sind
viele fehler gemacht wurden von vielen
verantwortlichen aber im vergleich zur
katastrophe 21 tote so viele hunderte
verletzte traumatisierte eine
riesenkatastrophe sind die einzelnen
fehler die gemacht wurden und die schuld
die jeder einzelne dafür zu tragen hat
vergleichsweise gering und deshalb sind
sie im strafrechtlichen sinne weil
strafrechtlich wird nur die individuelle
schuld eines jeden einzelnen beurteilt
und die ist so gering dass es am ende
nach solchen katastrophen fast immer nur
freisprüche bewährungsstrafen gibt oder
wie heute gar kein urteil
vielen dank für diese erklärung in der
attacke was steckt hinter dem brutalen
angriff auf das team der zdf heute show
bei dem fünf mitarbeiter zum teil
erheblich verletzt wurden
noch ist vieles unklar die
staatsanwaltschaft berlin ermittelt
jetzt wegen gefährlicher
körperverletzung gegen eine gruppe von
15 personen
einige von ihnen sollen die zdf
mitarbeiter gezielt angegriffen haben
unter anderem mit einem metallgegenstand
das team hatte am ersten mai den
kabarettisten abdel karim begleitet der
sprach heute über den vorfall
peter böhme berichten was ist hier
passiert und warum immer noch ist vieles
unklar bei dem angriff auf das team um
satiriker abdel karim am freitag völlig
unerwartet sei der angriff gekommen
lebensbedrohlich sagen die die dabei
waren verdacht auf gefährliche
körperverletzung nennt das die
staatsanwaltschaft es ging so schnell
man hat eigentlich nichts sehen können
außer liegt dunkel gekleidet ist schon
hauptsächlich schwarz gekleidete
vermummte leute die von jetzt auf gleich
noch einmal da waren und da wurde auch
mit tritten auf dem boden liegende ins
gesicht geschlagen also das ist schon
wirklich unübersichtlich und dynamisch
sei die lage gewesen so die ermittler
die aufklärung aufwendig und schwierig
vier männer und zwei frauen vorläufig
festgenommen sind inzwischen wieder auf
freiem fuß
sie sind nach polizeilichen
erkenntnissen teilweise der linken szene
zuzurechnen
ob dieser umstand möglicherweise die
tatmotivation begründete ist aktuell
gegenstand der ermittlungen so die
staatsanwaltschaft
geprüft wird auch ein möglicher
zusammenhang mit dem drehort des heute
show teams eine zusammenkunft von
kritikern der korona maßnahmen
verschiedenste strömungen treffen sich
hier
egal aus welchem grund auch gewalt sei
immer sinnlos sagt abdel karim
hoffentlich alle auch den schock
verkraften verarbeiten das leben wird
nochmal weiter gehen und dass man sagt
diskussionskultur sieht anders aus
also eigentlich dachte ich dass dieser
anschlag wenn man denn so nennen kann
hätte ich das nicht für möglich gehalten
das ist wirklich passiert also man muss
dass man auch mal sagen kann ich finde
deine meinung scheiße ich bin deine
scheiße aber ich werde jetzt hier auch
die zu rennen und ich kaputt schlagen
es gibt eine vielzahl von zeugenaussagen
bildern und beweismitteln auszuwerten
der staatsschutz ermittelt zum fussball
am mittwoch soll auch entschieden werden
ob der ball künftig zumindest in
geisterspielen wieder rollen darf heute
teilte die dfl mit in der ersten und
zweiten bundesliga sind insgesamt zehn
corona infektionen festgestellt worden
die drei bekannten fälle beim ersten fc
köln inklusive
empörung löste dieses
video aus salomon kalou von hertha bsc
der mitschüler immer wieder die hand
gibt und so gegen die hygiene
vorschriften verstößt
der bundesligist präsentierte sein
stürmer mit sofortiger wirkung das
wetter soll wieder sonniger werden die
details hat gleich gunther tiersch claus
kleber begrüßt sie im heute journal um
viertel vor zehn
danke für ihr interesse machen sie sich
noch einen schönen abend soweit möglich
und bis morgen wenn sie mir auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
im namen der zuschauer es bleibt bei uns
noch ziemlich kühl aber es wird jeden
tag ein bisschen freundlicher werden 20
grad werden wir heute wie im süden nicht
mehr erreichen liegen über frankreich
morgen aber zwei tage dann sind diese 20
grad wieder bei uns und heiß ist es vor
allen dingen im süden von spanien
temperaturen derzeit bis zu 30 grad bei
uns ist es eher kühl
heute nacht bei dem klaren himmel
anfangs ziehen ja noch regenschauer über
das erzgebirge und im südöstlichen
bayern gegen die alpen
später wird es dann auch dort trocken
sein ja bei dem klaren himmel wird halt
leichter frost in der mitte und im
norden zum teil bis -2 grad mild ist es
im süden morgen früh 6 bis 10 grad und
auch tagsüber wird es dort am wärmsten
werden am rhein an der donau 15 bis 19
grad an den alpen aber und auch in der
mitte und im norden ist es kühler mit 10
bis 14 grad aber es ist sonnig in
norddeutschland ähnlich wie heute und im
osten ziehen wieder dichte wolken durch
mit ein paar schauern von der ostsee und
dazu haben wir diesen kräftigen nord bis
nordwestwind auch in der mitte und im
süden scheint zeitweise die sonne an der
donau wird dann bewölkter bis zu den
alpen und hier in den alpen ziehen immer
wieder regenschauer durch in den
nächsten tagen ist es dann allerdings
wieder trocken es wird sonnig und die
temperaturen werden langsam ansteigen
ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen
abend und machen sie's gut